[Music]
for the Thanksgiving live special with
Michael Shanks and John Billingsley
Daniel Jackson and flocks from Star Trek
Enterprise we were asked by the
companion to do a little silly little
question and obviously us being
Sidetrack I had to get a fake goatee
right to be the Mir Universe J
clearly when this popped up I was very
very embarrassed and I was really wored
to see what Michael shags and John
Billingsley would actually how how they
would react to asy little skit but they
laughed so hey if you want to see the
full clip that we did um there is a a
link in the description but it's on the
channel and please go over to the
companion um the video the four
Thanksgiving episode is now on their
YouTube channel go and give it a like
and give them a subscribe show them some
sidet Trek love now here is me trying to
act oh God enjoy yeah yeah it's uh it's
been it's a lot of gray in this
[Laughter]
beard so we have one more question to
round out this segment um and it's a one
that was sent in from our friends over
at citrek
um so let's take a look at
that oh Jay I got this new app it's
called Quantum mirror it's really cool
watch this
right that was weird have you always had
that goate to am I in the Mirror
Universe what's your favorite sport
kicking babies probably okay this ABS
really weird hang on let me go
back Michael what would Daniel Jackson's
Mirror Universe character be like and
John you played an amazing miror
Universe character in Enterprise he was
properly evil how much fun is it to play
just a complete psycho villain like that
and what advice could you give Michael
if he was to play an evil Daniel
Jackson I never I've learned never give
another actor
[Laughter]
advice oh you want to go first Michael
uh sure I I I think that in in an evil
Mirror Universe uh all I would do my
character would um me his evil Universe
double would be played by David huet
that's it do with that what you will and
so I think that when we did an episode
together um on Atlantis that that was
probably Daniel and his evil twin played
by McKay so uh that's that's how I
always remember it anyway
nice I I've played more evil characters
than good characters down the years I I
I find the one the one characteristic
that always sort of takes you down a
long road is Joy the evil characters are
are enjoying their their what they're
doing uh you wouldn't be doing it if you
weren't enjoying it so um you know uh
wherever GLE what made Anthony Hopkins
so brilliant as uh Hannibal Lector is
that he's he so loves his
work
[Music]